the jungle is perfectly safe
four means so much to so many people
around the world what does it mean to
you to play I mean I'm just honored I
mean I feel like it's kind of meant to
be though considering my whole life I've
been called Dora because I have the
bangs I had the hair I was kind of
asking for it
and I also spoke Spanish most of my life
so it's an honor and I think that really
it's the perfect time for this kind of
movie too I think and more you know that
it's most most people go to the cinemas
are Hispanic the most people buy their
tickets they make up 50% of the audience
usually and so finally they're going to
see some proper representation with the
whole Hispanic cast and from all
different cultures as well you know
Jeffrey Wahlberg's Dominican half
Dominican even when going on Michael
Pena or any other of is Mexican so I'm
just really really excited I'm yeah you
know the poster says that Explorer is
Dora's middle name but we thought though
was a middle name do we find out what
her middle name or last name listen I'm
gonna talk to Paramount right now I was
I I dropped that out in my in my post on
Instagram I was like you guys doesn't
make any sense
I'm Doris number one fan listen I was
pissed that he did enough boots in the
commercial in the commercial the trailer
and he will have I did see an ad RDS
boots on so like I don't know what
happened there
but yeah I'm just I am excited to see
like because at least in the script in
the movie they pay tribute properly to
the original show I don't know what the
I don't know what the press is doing I
don't I don't know but I know in the
movie you're guaranteed a solid
experience you should turn to the
audience and ask the audience questions
yeah yeah for sure I mean the people of
other characters that move you're like
what the hell are you doing but like
Jordan knows what's up you guys will
know what's up yeah I play
Dora's mother Elena and we are
archaeologists explorers when you meet
Michael Benny and I as her parents you
understand who Dora is and why she
the whole origin of the the the brand of
Dora is because of we raise this child
the way we raised her and so it was a
lot of fun to bring that to life
you